I do believe in putting in years on the
road Gladwell ten thousand hours ten
thousand hours at least and for me and
what was weird when I when I came up uh
the one thing I could always get like
Studio demo time in London but I never
could get signed and my voice was always
used as the reason why I couldn't why I
I failed because I was like yeah and
there's a year's Voice not very good you
can't sing and and uh it's not that
funny
can't sing um because you know because
everyone's a critical and and I was just
learning I was learning and I was
learning in public and I and I was
failing public and I was someone asked
me yesterday what's the best piece of
advice you ever got during music and I
was I was racking my brain so I was
remembering that I once in my band just
before I began Bush
um I thought trying to be really
inclusive with the band I was in I said
to the drummer and we're walking onto
the stages the king's head Pub in Fulham
it's a really unwell known place and uh
unless you live around the corner right
and uh we walked up on stage and I was
thinking you know in the spirit of the
band what should I say to him hey buddy
is uh anything I should you know
anything I should look out for he goes
yeah yeah watch the high notes
right that'll give you a lot of
confidence
I still I walk onto a stage I step up
and I think watch The Hideout what was
the changing moment for you when you
started to finally feel like you were
good because you know I think the
changing moment was when I um was when I
met Nigel in the band and I I used to
always write with other people and I was
you know I'm still not that necessarily
a great a good guitar player I'm a
guitar player for to write songs I have
a genius guitar player and I'm I'm
getting better but uh you know you still
practice so I I do lessons I do lessons
every week I do them in French to
practice my French so I probably could
be better why I just don't know
yeah I get about three quarters of it
what part of your guitar playing don't
you like would you can you shred the
guitar can you can you do the yeah well
I can't shred but I do I I just do
arpeggios with him with things where the
moving fingers and I like when you do
the fifths and he goes uh man not only
can't they can't
but so I I used to always look right
with other people okay and when I was in
between bands and and depressed and
looking for for work I was I was
contacting different guitar players and
suddenly I sat down one day and I said
you know you're a jerk if you call
yourself a songwriter you give yourself
to music and you study and you want to
do this sit down and write a song with a
guitar already what are you doing why
are you leaning on people so I sat down
and the first song I ever wrote was a
come down and and I was like well it's
not that okay is that that's the first
song you ever wrote the first song I
ever wrote on my own no [ __ ] and I took
it and I took it I took it to my guitar
player this guy and he was real busy guy
and I was just another kid jerk coming
along trying to start a band with him
and he was making good money doing
Jingles so he'd say I say you know do
you want to write together he said no no
no I think it's better if you bring
songs you've got I said yeah I I got one
he didn't realize I was the only one I
had so I brought in come down he goes oh
and he he put it he did the demo for me
and we put it down and I suddenly was
like that sounds pretty good how did you
get over all that rejection what made
you keep going when everybody's saying I
got nothing to fall back on I bet
exactly I'll tell you when I first
finished um 16 stone that where that
record is on
um I signed a deal with this small
independent label in the valley everyone
was saying do not sign you know from
London a deal in the valley you never go
see this guy again I I'm I've got to
make the record and then there was a
tragic uh the Frank Wells who was the
head of uh Disney and he had that
Hollywood Records and um he died
tragically in a in a helicopter crash so
we they took they inherited the 16 Stone
record that had like five number one
records on it and sold I know 20 million
copies itself and he they said not only
the no album tracks there's not any of
those singles on this record there's no
album tracks and so we got dropped so I
went back to work and I painted a 11 uh
identical offices
dentist offices because I used to paint
and decorate to make money to make music
and there were 11 of them so it's like a
Kafka nightmare because he's beginning
you finished one on my own food and then
halfway in the half during that four
month process I got a call they said uh
your record is broken on K-Rock I was
like that's great what's chaos
foreign